[Music]
it was the last saturday in september of
2021
as the sky darkened over downtown
toronto a team of drone specialists and
doctors held their breath
nestled inside that black box are human
lungs a priceless life-saving gift from
a donor about to be airlifted for the
first time by drone to a recipient at
toronto general hospital
so this is the roof this is the roof
waiting on the roof that night was dr
shaf khashoggi director of the toronto
lung transplant program so you've got
all those checks and balances in place
right you've tested it and tested it how
did you actually feel at night
in nervous because you know like in an
operating room i can be in control and
an understanding and and respond to
everything i'm trained to respond to it
with a drone
hovering over your head like
i
can't do anything about it out of your
control it's out of my control it's life
that you're transporting in that little
box yeah yeah no no it is
the journey took just six minutes and
though they'd done more than 50 test
flights with a dummy payload there were
still fears the gps might fail or a bird
might attack we were in contact with
them and we knew it would take on but we
couldn't see it right we're standing
there waiting waiting waiting then what
happens is it comes over toronto general
and it kind of stops and hovers and it's
probably only three or four seconds but
it but it seemed like an age like i'm
thinking like
just come down you know
several floors below waiting in a
hospital bed was 63 year old ellen odak
in
an hour or two hours they're going to
fix my lungs
i was really at the end of the line i
was on major quantities of oxygen just
to get up just to walk around his lungs
scarred by pulmonary fibrosis were
operating at less than 10 percent
capacity when the lungs are shot and
they're not going to get better the
writing is on the wall
he had weeks to live
dr khashoggi and his team were pushing
the limits doing something that had
never been done before and needed
consent from the potential recipient
they came to the room in the afternoon
and they said we've got this project
that's transporting by drones are you
interested in participating they
describe the risk of it
and i said
i'm a technical guy i'm an engineer by
profession
i said advancement of science sure i'll
participate
his life was hanging in the balance
dependent on this delivery
we're just
unhooking the lung from the from the
drone right now as we speak hope you
have some champagne there
and it was no ordinary drone it was
specially designed by uniter
bioelectronics in bromont quebec to have
multiple backup systems and we built in
a ballistic parachute so with two
engines ballistic parachutes right so if
the if the the drone drops too fast tilt
suddenly loses power it will cut all the
engines a parachute will fire and the
drone will come down to the ground
safely and it was very exciting because
like drone guys are like cool engineer
dudes and they can do all that stuff but
they didn't sort of think like it's a
line well gave a drone crashes i'll just
get another one well no
it's got a lung in it that's a person
that's someone's life
how far was it flying that night but
it's kind of like the kitty hawk right
it's like the first flight it is the
first flight and actually the most
difficult part of drone flight like if
we can fly in the middle of downtown
toronto safely we can fly anywhere in
north america it is another step in dr
khashoggi's grand plan to streamline the
complex logistics of organ transplants
they're the most fragile and the most
challenging of the major organs so
kidneys were transplanted first then the
heart and liver and lungs lagged behind
for almost two decades
lung transplants are his life's work
he's been focused on them since medical
school in the 1980s and i was very
fortunate that when i was training here
at the university of toronto the first
successful lung transplant in the world
was being performed right here at
toronto general hospital it was quite
amazing but it also you know as a young
student hit me that wow it really is a
miracle but it's extremely risky it
doesn't really work that often that was
39 years ago this is the air being
reintroduced into the new lung and it
was the moment dr khashoggi decided to
devote himself to lungs making multiple
improvements steadily increasing the
number of successful lung transplants
good evening everybody
thank you for having me here
here he is at a ted med talk in san
diego in 2010 i've done hundreds of lung
transplants and yet every single time i
do that operation it i marvel at what we
do he invented a technique to keep donor
lungs alive outside the body so they
could be evaluated even treated made
healthier and tailored to the recipient
we set out to say
can we genetically modify organs so that
they're better
prepared to deal with the stress of a
transplant
it's called ex-vivo lung perfusion or
evlp and this lung is alive so while
it's sitting here it's not dying anymore
we're facilitating recovery
what are you doing
it's interesting versions of the
invention are now being used around the
world that's when we showed you could
keep a lung for 12 hours outside the
body at 37 degrees with no deterioration
and function remember i told you lung
cells start dying in 20 minutes so that
was remarkable like when we did that we
knew we'd hit a home run in this process
how long now can you keep a lung
functioning and healthy outside the body
we're looking at taking lungs to 36
hours to 72 hours outside the body i
mean that means you know you get along
on friday you can book it book it for
monday morning and not only a lung
that's deteriorated over time but
actually could be made better by monday
morning he envisions one day having lung
hospitals where donor organs would be
taken to be treated and healed and
prepared for the specific recipient
ultimately really the new frontier will
be can we modify it so that it looks
more like you more like self so you
won't reject it can we use your own stem
cells to make a lung that is you the
other new frontier is in the sky
uniter bioelectronics is developing
autonomous airborne organ delivery
systems
drones that can fly manned or unmanned
within congested cities or even hundreds
of kilometers between cities
when did you connect the dots between
drones and organ donation sometimes the
barrier to transplant is just logistics
can be as much as we can't get a plane
or there's a snowstorm or there's we
don't have staff or the operating rooms
are busy well if we can now have a
system where we don't have an operating
room we put the lung on evlp when
there's a room and a surgeon ready we do
a lung transplant so we can now do five
lung transplants in a day five patients
we used to do one a day right so it's
looking at logistics like that so the
next thing was the the transportation of
organs this was the first lung delivery
by drone but other medical teams have
done similar tests with different organs
i'm pretty nervous let's not screw it
in 2019 in baltimore maryland we're for
launch let's make some history
this drone carried a human kidney
getting a little breezy up here from a
recipient to a donor
another successful test that it's hoped
will one day make oregon transport
simpler and less expensive you have a
plane
to take the team to go pick up the
organs and come back but you have five
different teams you have lung liver
kidney heart teams all going so often
one donor hospital will have five teams
and five planes coming from five
different places pick up their organ and
go back to their hospital and find more
plane trips
just to transport an organ that weighs
two kilograms
when i was here last i was pushing him
in a wheelchair la odak is back on his
feet breathing easy and he's just
welcomed his first grandchild and is
looking forward to more i was given a
second life
really that's what it is basically is
thanks to a generous donor i have now a
second life the the lucky coincidence
was he's like an engineer that just
thought this was the coolest thing that
ever could have happened yeah and he's
doing amazingly well and he calls what's
happened to him a second life it is it
is because you know i mean people live
on the lung transplant list knowing that
one in five of them will die before they
can get along in time by constantly
innovating it's our best attempt
currently to mimic what's inside the
body dr kashaf ji's vision is that organ
transplants will one day be as routine
and commonplace as hip replacements i
can't see
hundreds of drones flying around yet
like how's that going to happen how's it
going to be safe you know i think
there's going to likely need to be lanes
in the sky of of of where drones go and
i think all of that needs to be figured
out but you know organ transplantation
is probably
a pretty important reason to really
figure that out
rather than delivering your laundry
detergent
i think most people would agree
[Music]